hi my name is Rhys I'm a councillor for
the villages Ward fourth an addition
consul one of the reasons why I wanted
to be a councillor was that I wanted to
effect positive change in my local area
and make sure that residents concerns
and views were heard at district council
level and you know if you want to be a
counsellor if you want to stand up for
the views and the rights of your
community and the residents around you
then you know please do stand to be a
counsellor you know it's an absolutely
fantastic role to do it's a great
opportunity you learn so so much you
know and it's just it is amazing it is
amazing and you know what I would say is
that you know we need more young people
here and we need the new jet new young
generation of councillors to come in and
to bring a bit of life into this chamber
and ensure that you know this council is
prepared for the future
you know so if you're young and you're
dedicated and you love where you live
and you want it to remain the wonderful
place that is then please consider
standing as a councillor
you